what's up ladies and gentlemen welcome
back to talking Thrones
unfortunately season seven has now ended
and we are gonna have another long wait
until season eight begins I know some of
you have been asking me what I'm gonna
do with my channel during the off season
so for those of you that do not know I
will continue making videos all year
even though the season is over I will
still release several videos each week
so I'm hoping all of you new subscribers
will stick around during this long night
as we head into the offseason in this
video I want to go over a few things
that are still unresolved as of right
now that we should see take place in
season 8 this isn't necessarily a
prediction video this is more like a
preview video also I know there are a
lot of season 8 leaks floating around
out there already but do not believe
those leaks they are 100% [ __ ] there
were a few different things that
happened in a season 7 finale that can
change the landscape in the last season
the final season will only have six
episodes but one of HBO's executives
said they want to make each episode in
season 8 feature film length somewhere
around 90 minutes per episode so even
though there is only six episodes left
the episodes will be long enough to give
us a full season worth of content and
considering how fast things are moved in
I think we can expect just about
anything to happen in season 8 so first
I want to talk about the relationship
between Jon Snow and Daenerys Targaryen
as we saw in the season 7 finale John
and Danny have honored the Targaryen
tradition by keeping it all in the
family ever since season 1 Daenerys has
assumed she can no longer have children
and they have made sure to remind us of
this several times in the last few
episodes but I think it's quite clear
now that Daenerys will in fact get
pregnant anyway as I have said in my
last video I believe death will pay for
life which will allow Daenerys to get
pregnant once again but not only will
she get pregnant I believe she will have
Jon Snow's child some of you said since
Jon Snow is a Targaryen and Daenerys is
a Targaryen that could be the perfect
ingredients I should say that would
allow for this to happen
some of you have also said since Jon
Snow has died it was his death that
would actually pay for life and that's
what will cause Daenerys to get pregnant
personally I still think it's because of
vissarion's death I think Daenerys had
to lose something close to her for her
to be able to pay for life but I do like
the idea about Daenerys needing to breed
with another Targaryen to allow her to
have children I do think that is a very
good candidate but now you have to
wonder about their relationship moving
forward we just got a massive revelation
thanks to brain stark and Samwell Tarly
Rhaegar and Lyanna were married and this
makes Jon Snow a legitimate Targaryen
and rightful heir to the Iron Throne
putting him in front of Daenerys
Targaryen same this news is going to
completely change the face of the
politics in Westeros although the Great
War is here this is going to make Dany
and John's relationship very awkward if
the Narus is in fact pregnant John is
gonna have to make a tough decision we
know that John is not gonna want a child
of his being born a bastard that was the
whole reason he was still a virgin in
the first place he told Sam the reason
why he never slept with Ross was because
what if he got her pregnant then there
would be another bastard named snow and
that's not a good life for a child she
was up there in the brothel as ROS took
off her clothes but I couldn't do it
because all I could think was what if I
got her pregnant she had a child another
bastard named snow
she's a good life for a child knowing
how John felt about this he will want to
marry Daenerys if he knows she is
pregnant with his child but can you
imagine how the north and possibly even
Songza would feel about all of this
happening at once as of right now no one
else knows the truth about jon snow's
parents in his claim for the iron throne
except for Brian Sam and Howland Reed we
have seen the north ready to revolt
against John now that he has left them
to go south and greet with a Targaryen
but we have also seen how the show is
changing as it heads towards its endgame
almost all the characters are learning
to accept others no matter their
differences in their past conflicts now
that the Great War is here all of that
has to be put to the side in order for
everyone to come together and defeat the
knight King this is something that's
gonna have to continue happening if
everybody wants to survive now that the
knight king is coming south I'm not so
sure if the northerners are gonna even
have time to question Jon Snow or
Daenerys I also think once they learn
what Daenerys has sacrificed to help
them they will be more understanding and
willing to work together they really
don't have a choice they're gonna have
to accept Daenerys for who she is and
Jon Snow for who he is when this big
revelation comes out and becomes public
knowledge I could see some of the
northerners being upset and angry and
leaving but they will not survive the
winter if they choose to do that the
first thing we will see is the night
King completely destroying the Nights
Watch then I believe he will head to
Winterfell and that's where we will see
a huge war as everyone tries to defend
it like I have said before I think the
Nights Watch will no longer have a
purpose after the Great War is over with
the wall being destroyed in everything
that was north of the wall now being
south already there will be no reason to
have a Night's Watch anymore if the
knight King and the army of the Dead get
defeated there will be nothing left
north of the wall that they will need to
protect the realm from as of right now
Cersei is the only one not willing to
play ball even though she knows the
threat is real she was given a
demonstration with the one white but she
still doesn't understand how serious
this threat actually is this is going to
severely complicate things for Jon and
Daenerys not only because they will not
have the Lena store troops helping them
but Cersei now has reinforcements on the
way from Essos so Jon and Daenerys could
potentially be facing an army on two
different fronts
jamie has finally woke up and realized
he can no longer stand by Cersei side
and support her madness Jaime's decision
to leave is also very interesting
because you have to wonder where he is
going to be going winter is now reaching
King's Landing so I can only imagine how
harsh the weather is going to be going
as he heads north but how will Jamie get
greeted when he arrives we know that Jon
and Daenerys was willing to put aside
their differences to fight together with
the Lannisters but Jon has no idea that
it was actually Jamie who pushed Brian
out of the tower window at Winterfell
brain did have a mash up version of
visions a few seasons ago and one of
those visions was him falling out of the
tower
but he still didn't see who pushed him
the only two people alive right now that
know this for a fact is Theon and
Brienne lady Catelyn was telling people
that the Lannisters were responsible for
this but all of those people are now
dead but Breen knows and she is in the
North but I don't see Bree and ever
snitching on Jamie I think she still
loves Jamie too much to see him be put
in a position of possibly being executed
for crippling Brian so I want to ask all
of you this everybody that is watching
and listening to this right now leave a
comment down below and let me know what
you think will happen with Jamie when
and if he makes it to Winterfell what
will happen if Brian Stark reveals the
truth about Jamie pushing him out of the
window let me know what you think about
that down below another interesting
thing to note about Jamie heading north
is now we are gonna have all the
Valyrian steel in one general place and
this was something I had talked about
before too
this isn't a coincidence now that the
Great War is here we're gonna need all
the Valyrian steel in this war being put
to use all of the Valyrian steel swords
in the show are now right where they
belong
Jamie also knows those swords were made
from Ned Stark's sword ice so I'm hoping
after the fighting has ended he could do
the right thing and leave that sword
with the Starks that's assuming he's
still alive after the war but I'm not so
sure Jamie's gonna survive this war he's
not really capable of defending himself
anymore the only reason why he has
survived this long is that a pure luck
in his Valyrian steel Plaut armor this
also puts Jamie in position of
fulfilling a prediction I made several
months ago now that Jamie is going north
he could end up sacrificing himself for
one of the Starks in order to complete
his own Redemption arc if Jamie has to
die that would be a great way for him to
go by putting himself on the line for
someone else someone that he had wronged
in the past but we will see the stage is
also being set for another Redemption
arc to be completed in season eight and
this is another prediction I have made
ever since spoiler photos came out
showing your Greyjoy being a prisoner of
euron greyjoy
Theon will take his small rescue team
and attempt to save Yara just like Yara
tried to save Theon back when Ramsay had
him as his captive but I have a feeling
Theon will be a little bit more
successful I know some of you completely
disagree with me about this but I
believe fian will complete his or
by putting his own life on the line
while attempting to set yar free and in
the process he will go head-to-head with
his uncle you're on Theon may die trying
and I can easily see that happening but
if he does he will die doing something
heroic for his sister who he abandoned
back in episode 2 there is only one
season left which means every single
characters arc will come to a close
whether you believe it or not this is
the awns arc just like I believe Jamie's
arc will be for one of those Starks this
story began with Jamie pushing a stark
out of the window and I think his story
may end by saving one of the Starks and
that person most likely being bran Stark
in some way but keep in mind I know
nothing it's gonna be interesting to see
what all they are able to fit into this
story during season eight with only six
episodes left
I truly am hoping they do make each
episode around 90 plus minutes like they
said they wanted to do there is still a
lot of story left to be told and even
with all of its flaws I am still very
excited to see how things turn out in
the end
so comment down below and let me know
what are some of your initial
predictions after seeing the season 7
finale what are some of the things that
you can see happening when the final
season begins I'm curious to hear all of
your thoughts I am going to begin on my
season 7 finale breakdown video now and
I should have that ready to upload
sometime tomorrow so I hope to see all
of you back for that one and like I said
earlier in this video even though the
season is over I will continue to make
videos all year so don't go anywhere
just yet I want to thank you all for
watching tonight's video I really do
hope you enjoyed it and I also want to
thank my patreon supporters your
generosity never goes unnoticed I hope
you all have a great night bye
you
you